Esta es la fachada de la embajada de
Rusia en Argentina y aquí está llegando
esta marcha que se encuentra a mis
espaldas convocada por la comunidad
ucraniana en este país una comunidad que
algunos estiman que podría estar en
torno al medio millón de miembros muchos
son descendientes de pasadas migraciones
a la Argentina y están aquí reclamando
cuando se cumple un año de la invasión
rusa Ucrania por la salida de las tropas
rusas de su país por la salida de Rusia
de Ucrania ya habían comenzado con este
tipo de marchas aquí mismo al inicio de
la invasión y ahora las están repitiendo
otra vez repitiendo el reclamo que se
inició hace un año y en este aniversario
vuelven a traer aquí a la embajada rusa
[Música]